braggs it now that the UK has officially
notified the European Council of its
intention to leave what's next the next
steps were agreed by all member states
years ago and are set out in article 50
of the EU treaty the other 27 leaders of
the European Council adopt guidelines
for negotiations with the UK those
guidelines can be amended throughout for
negotiation The ministers in the Council
of the EU also meeting in an EU 27
former authorized the opening of
negotiations they appoint the Commission
as the EU negotiator and adopts
negotiating directives on behalf of the
eu-27 the Commission negotiates with the
UK reporting back to the leaders in the
European Council and the ministers in
the council the European Parliament is
closely and regularly informed for as
long as the UK remains a member of the
EU it participates in all European
Council and council meetings except when
Braves it is disgusting after the end of
negotiation the consent of the European
Parliament is required the deal is then
ready to be concluded by the council
when the agreements entered into force
the UK is no longer an EU member and the
EU treaties cease to apply to it find
out more on the council website
you